[Musique]
comédien de génie acteur caméléon
capable de jouer le tragique le comique
souvent les deux ont même temps notre
invité a donné la réplique dans des
dizaines de pièces de films de série les
planches la télévision le cinéma les
plateformes il a interprété tous les
rôles possibles et imaginables les pires
comme les plus sympathiques des monstres
des monsieur tout le monde des avocats
engagés profond des politiques aussi
parlementaires ministre président de la
République il colle à la peau de ses
personnages et il le dit lui-même il
adore changer de peau jouer un rôle en
tournage la journée et passer un autre
personnage le soir sur scène mais alors
quand est-il lui-même à force d'être les
autres Perton un peu de soi de sa propre
identité posant lui toutes ces questions
bienvenue dans un monde un regard
bienvenue Laurent Stocker de la Comédie
Française merci d'être avec nous au Dôme
Tournon au Sénat aujourd'hui je le dis
avec un peu d'humour mais qui est
Laurent Stocker est-ce qu'on le sait
encore quand on joue au temps de rôle et
qu'on change comme ça dans une même
journée de Pau si vous savez
moi je suis moi-même évidemment mais
j'aime bien les phrases de Montaigne qui
disent moi aujourd'hui et moi tantôt
sommes bien deux ça colle bien à
l'acteur et il se trouve autant de
différence de moi à moi-même que de moi
à autrui on dit toujours que la le pire
ennemi c'est soi-même et quand on est
acteur je pense que on a cette chance de
pouvoir effectivement faire des rôles
totalement différents et exulter
quelquefois quand on a quand on est
malheureux ou quand on est en colère on
peut le faire dans un rôle certains le
font avec le sport il y en a qui a aidé
nous on le fait dans les rôles est-ce
que parfois c'est quand même compliqué
de changer de personnages est-ce que
quand on sort d'un film d'un rôle d'une
série où le rôle a été fort est-ce que
c'est difficile de se retrouver soit ou
de sortir de la de la force d'un
personnage alors je crois que ça dépend
des ça dépend des personnes
en ce qui me concerne dès que le
tournage est fini je redeviens moi-même
et je ne suis plus en train de ruminer
tous les soirs et que il faut à nouveau
remettre son son son ouvrage et se dire
que on va faire un avare qui sera un peu
différent de celui d'hier et que ce sera
pas le même de celui que de celui de
demain il faut trouver cette énergie là
et moi l'énergie je la trouve dans le
rire
quand même c'est fatigant parler non
c'est parce que en fait voilà il faut
moi je passe par le rire l'humour et le
rire c'est la façon de me
[Musique]
concentrer et puis il y a plusieurs
écoles du jeu il y a l'école américaine
ou on apprend aux acteurs on appuie sur
un bouton il pleure dans la seconde et
puis l'école française ou on aurait
tendance à être le rôle plus qu'à le
jouer oui alors il y a l'école aussi
russe
Stanislavski qui est un petit peu
l'ancêtre de de l'école américaine mais
c'est vrai que les américains ils ont ce
côté s'il joue un drogué il faut qu'il
se drogue si en France on n'a pas on n'a
pas ce on a pas cette approche enfin moi
je ne l'ai pas en tout cas vous avez
aussi une réflexion intéressante sur le
tragique et le comique et j'en ai un
tout petit peu parlé en introduction
vous adorez faire rire mais vous
cherchez quand même toujours le tragique
dans un personnage comique et
inversement d'ailleurs vous dites qui
est un peu des deux dans chacun dans
chacun de ces rôles je crois que c'est
Edward bon d'un auteur que j'aime
beaucoup qui dit le tragique et le
comique ne sont espacés que de quelques
secondes quelques minutes quelques
heures au maximum c'est vrai et un
acteur qui fait plutôt du des rôles
comiques moi c'est il se trouve qu'au
théâtre tu fais plutôt du comique je ne
l'envisage jamais comme un rôle comique
en fait le rôle comique doit être
envisagé comme une chose très sérieuse
si vous avez si vous si vous imaginez
que le comique c'est vraiment le clin
d'oeil au public et c'est la chose qui
va être forcément drôle ça sera pas
drôle alors que si vous êtes dans le
tragique de la situation qui se trouve
être comique ce sera comique de Funès
étant l'exemple absolu de ça il joue à
fond le truc alors après évidemment il y
a des il y a des il y a des il y a des
il y a des méthodes de fitness entre
guillemets il y a du mais c'est une
horloge suisse c'est ce que dit Bergson
sur le rire et oui ok de la mécanique
plaqué sur du vivant quelque chose de
mécanique dans quelque chose de vivant
c'est Louis de Funès c'est exactement ça
c'est dans la gestuelle il se sert son
corps pour être comique sia la mécanique
et qui a pas le vivant c'est pas drôle
si elle vivant et qui a pas la mécanique
c'est pas drôle non plus vous quiez les
deux et c'est toujours l'exemple de
la personne qui est avec vous dans la
rue qui
qui vous tient le bras ou la main et
puis qui tombe et là tout le monde rit
et la personne se relève pas et tout le
monde pleure et en fait la tragédie et
la comédie ne sont pas très très
espacées enfin c'est moi je les je les
envisage toujours comme quelque chose de
très proche en fait et à ce titre il y a
aussi Michel Serrault je crois que vous
prenez comme exemple vous dites une
école de théâtre à lui tout seul Michel
Serrault c'est un des plus grands
acteurs qui existait en France parce
qu'il avait cette capacité là à passer à
des rôles comiques et des rôles
tragiques il avait cette force là il a
la comédie extraordinaire de la cage aux
folles et puis il a il a gardé
avec cette scène où il dit oui il sort
de de la garde à vue justement et sa
femme s'est suicidé dans la voiture
c'est c'est
c'est des émotions et en même temps se
détachement moi j'aime beaucoup se
détachement ce côté en fait ça reste
ça reste du théâtre c'est pas grave mais
en même temps salé c'est compliqué parce
que tout ça est très tenu en fait on est
sur un film on est sur un fil moi je
suis toujours sur un fil quand je joue
les les
et c'est ce qui est intéressant chez les
acteurs c'est l'acteur qui est
qui est dans le présent et qui n'est pas
en train de débiter son texte pour la
énième fois de la même façon et Michel
Serrault avait ça d'ailleurs j'ai pu
parler avec des gens qui avaient
travaillé avec lui il fallait toujours
trois caméras parce qu'il faisait jamais
les mêmes prises et quelquefois même il
bougeait alors il était plus dans le
cadre enfin mais en même temps quand
vous voyez les films avec ces robes
c'est c'est extraordinaire c'est une
école d'acteur à lui tout seul je crois
que quelquefois je discute avec des
jeunes qui ont une vingtaine d'années et
ils me disent je sais pas qui est Michel
Serrault alors je dis ben ça vous
effraie ça m'est frais le temps passe et
je leur offre souvent des des DVD et
disent merci merci parce que
ils apprennent si on revient sur votre
histoire plus personnelle devenir acteur
était une évidence quasiment depuis
toujours il y a eu l'influence de votre
grand-père dont vous étiez très proche
sa maison était mitoyenne de la vôtre à
ville-sur-saône près de Bar-le-Duc dans
la Meuse certainement c'est lui qui m'a
donné le goût de la scène dites-vous il
jouait de la clarinette de la batterie
je l'entends des jouets quand je
rentrais de l'école et vous ajoutez une
chose incroyable il ne savait pas lire
les notes de musique dites-vous il
faisait tout en impro c'était un
personnage un comédien c'est un comédien
c'était c'était cette partie de
familiale qui était en fait des immigrés
italiens qui sont venus travailler en
Lorraine donc après ils se sont mariés
avec des lorins et des Alsaciens ça a
donné cette chose étrange parce qu'on
peut pas dire que je sois vraiment un
très grand brun
mais c'était des c'était des Italiens du
Piémont donc il y a eu les invasions
autrichiennes donc dans le piment il y a
beaucoup de blonds et ce grand-père en
question effectivement il était très
fantasque et très
c'était un comédien né en fait il
faisait les balles populaires il faisait
y jouer toujours on a été bercé par la
musique mais avec quelqu'un qui ne
connaissait pas les notes de musique
donc qui jouaient des airs moi je suis
flotter des airs en pensant que c'était
des choses que des compositeurs avaient
fait mais c'était juste lui qui
composait des musiques ou des morceaux
alors que et puis à la clarinette oui
c'était donc il y avait s'il y avait ce
côté quand même
dans l'enfance le côté quand même
théâtrale et le côté spectaculaire et
vous l'avez dit vous êtes un enfant de
la Lorraine une région minière ouvrière
jusqu'à 16 ans qui a été
pas mal abimée par la
désindustrialisation région aussi
considérée comme abandonnée parfois mise
de côté est-ce que vous en gardez une
force d'être issue de cette de cette
région là est-ce qu'il y a une identité
particulière quand on quand on vient de
là-bas
on peut pas se détacher de ses racines
et de l'endroit où on vient c'est des
régions ce sont des régions qui sont des
régions difficiles où les gens ont des
ont des
ils ont été cabossés des gens cabossé
moi j'aime beaucoup c'est d'ailleurs
dans les rôles j'aime beaucoup jouer ces
rôles là aussi c'est des gens à qui on
ne donne pas la parole c'est des gens
qui sont qui subissent qui se taisent et
qui après se fâche très fort voilà et
c'est il faut essayer de discuter avec
eux pour savoir comment faire pour
pouvoir leur redonner une une
une force une c'est important c'est
important donc ce que ce que je garde de
cette région c'est la prêter la dureté
quand j'aborde un rôle ou quelque chose
qui va être difficile ça ne me fait pas
peur parce que j'ai vu j'ai vu dans ma
famille des gens qui avaient pas peur de
de du travail de descendre dans des
mines et de faire des travails après des
travail difficiles donc après quand on
fait ce métier là on se dit ouais
j'apprenne tout Figaro c'est énorme et
par rapport à par rapport à eux par
rapport à ce que ces gens ont vécu ou
vivent c'est rien et elle a lueur de
celui que vous êtes aujourd'hui
quel conseil vous donneriez au petit
garçon ou jeune homme qui va se lancer
dans la vie qu'est-ce que vous lui
diriez avant qu'il ne se lance
qui ne
qui n'oublie jamais ses rêves qui
n'oublient jamais qu'un rêve de départ
peut devenir une réalité une belle
réalité et que une utopie peut devenir
une réalité aussi et que c'est souvent
par le prisme de l'enfance qu'on arrive
à
s'accomplir dans un métier artistique
entre autres ou autre d'ailleurs
ou un arc culinaire ou que sais-je mais
c'est souvent des gens qui ont perdu
leur rêve d'enfants qui deviennent des
personnes malheureuses en fait moi je
dis aux jeunes aux jeunes acteurs je lui
dis mais dire j'aimerais tellement être
acteur mais j'arriverai jamais j'ai dit
bah là si vous partez dans ce principe
là c'est sûr que ça part mal il faut que
vous partiez d'une idée
intense qui va vous amener à devenir ce
que vous avez envie d'être et ne jamais
oublier quand vous serez plus grand
quand vous serez adulte quand vous serez
même
âgé
quel est le regard que l'enfant que vous
avez été aurait eu sur vous vieux
quand pourtant vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure vous avez quitté la Lorraine à
l'âge de 16 ans pour rejoindre la
capitale Paris quand vous arrivez sur
Paris l'une des premières choses que
vous faites c'est ce que j'ai lu vous
allez peut-être me le confirmer c'est
d'aller vous recueillir sur la tombe de
Molière
j'étais allé voir la tombe de Molière et
j'étais je m'étais dit tiens il à côté
de la fontaine et en même temps c'est
c'est des ossements parce qu'il y a plus
rien dans sa paille il y a des ossements
mais comme Molière a été enterré dans la
fosse commune puisqu'il avait été
excommunié étant donné qu'il était
comédien et que c'était un métier très
mal vu moins maintenant mais il y a
quand même encore des sphères
de de public qui qui nous considèrent un
peu comme des saltimbins ou des gens un
petit peu en marge etc ce qui est très
bien et ce que je revendique d'ailleurs
mais oui oui je suis allé sur la tombe
de Molière le premier truc que j'ai fait
et je devais sauter quelques étapes le
bac au lycée Lamartine les ateliers
Gérard Philipe le Conservatoire national
supérieur d'art dramatique des études de
lettres à la Sorbonne et puis l'entrée à
la Comédie Française en 2001 vous en
devenez société en 2004 et là on entre
vraiment dans un univers assez méconnu
pour les gens qui nous écoutent pour moi
y compris d'ailleurs et ça m'intéresse
d'explorer ce monde avec vous comment
entre-t-on à la Comédie Française et
comment on devient-on sociétaire et
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire qu'est-ce que
ça implique en ce qui me concerne par
erreur
et puis par
par un jeu de coïncidence très étrange
je suis en Amérique du Sud je remplace
un comédien qui est Alexandre Pavlov qui
a un problème assez grave et qui doit se
faire hospitaliser
je suis sur place à ce moment là moi je
suis en vacances
parce que ma compagne joue dans la pièce
et on me dit ben on va pas faire venir
quelqu'un de la Comédie Française donc
ce qui serait bien c'est que tu puisses
jouer le rôle ce soir j'ai dit
je vais le lire je vais le lire je vais
te
et puis à la suite de ça
l'administrateur me dit mais
enfin fait demander à une actrice est-ce
que Laurent aimerait rentrer à la
Comédie Française et je dis ah non non
j'ai pas du tout envie pourquoi parce
que pour moi c'était à l'époque quand
j'étais au Conservatoire la Comédie
Française c'était vraiment le temple de
de ce qu'il fallait pas faire
quand on est un jeune acteur on a envie
de faire des pièces underground on a
envie de faire un théâtre décalé on a
envie du pas de côté
[Musique]
dans ces dans cette sphère dans ces
ordres dans ce dans ce dans ce protocole
dans cette hiérarchie etc et puis on se
rend compte que le protocole la
hiérarchie tout en la respectant elle
est aussi là pour être un petit peu
bafoué pour être un petit peu détruite
entre guillemets et que c'est ça qui
fait avancer aussi ce théâtre là parce
que simolierre
facile la troupe de Molière a créé cet
endroit c'est parce que en fait
la scie sur nous se renouveler en
permanence et sinon il serait plus
debout ce théâtre il serait déjà j'ai un
document vous proposer Laurent Stocker
alors je vais le lire de toute façon
vous inquiétez pas pour le public qui
nous écoute c'est un document délivré
par nos partenaires les Archives
nationales il s'agit d'une lettre de la
ministre de la Culture Catherine taska
autorisant la sortie du film
documentaire de Raymond de pardon sur la
campagne de Valéry Giscard d'Estaing à
la présidentielle de 74 son titre
1974 une partie de campagne et cette
lettre tenez-vous bien date de février
2002 ça veut dire qu'il aura fallu
attendre 28 ans avant que cette œuvre ne
soit plus censurée vous qui jouez pas
mal dans des fictions politiques est-ce
que pour vous ce délai ce document dit
quelque chose de l'opacité des milieux
de pouvoir de leur difficulté à ouvrir
leurs portes de la frilosité lever le
voile sur les sur leur coulisses
tout dépend des événements qui sont
traversés par le documentaire ou par la
fiction en question
il est vrai que par exemple pour ou
c'est Kin c'est Disney plus qu'il a
produit c'est pas une chaîne française
c'est pas voilà c'est les Américains qui
ont produit ou c'est qui effectivement
peut-être que les politiques auraient
tout intérêt à l'avoir moins peur de de
cette prise de parole qui pourrait
redevenir une prise de parole où elle
serait inclue dans un acte citoyen en
fait et que le politique qui s'éloigne
du citoyen va être à mon avis dans le
faux et le citoyen qui s'éloigne de la
politique je pense sera dans le faux
aussi enfin parlons justement quelques
minutes de ces fictions sur le monde
politique qui commence un peu à se
développer en France c'est pas si ancien
que ça vous vous êtes député puis
ministre dans jeu d'influence saison 1
et 2 sur Arte président de la République
dont sous contrôle sur Arte toujours et
lui meilleure série en compétition
française par le jury du dernier
festival série de Mania on a
l'impression qu'on commence tout juste
en France à oser s'attaquer à cet
univers sous forme de fiction alors
qu'on les Américains ou les anglais
l'ont fait beaucoup plus que nous et de
façon beaucoup plus trash nous on y va à
pas de loup j'ai envie de dire ouais en
même temps les séries que vous venez de
citer par exemple jeux d'influence c'est
quand même des séries qui ont se
méritent de rentrer aussi dans le cœur
de la politique et de raconter ce que
peut être une déception politique ou
alors un film que j'avais fait qui
s'appelait L'Exercice de l'État qui
racontait bien
les tenants et les aboutissants et le
moment où le politique peut se heurter à
quelque chose et il ne peut plus avancer
parce que des influences diverses l'en
empêche
notamment des lobbies d'ailleurs
c'est le cas de mais en fait il faut je
crois oui il faut pas avoir peur de ces
séries là elles sont très bien et elles
sont vous protège particulier à jouer
des responsables politiques
ah bah c'est plaisant à jouer qu'est-ce
qui pourquoi qu'est-ce que ça ils sont
traités ils sont très théâtre la norme
politique ou une femme politique en fait
ils sont sans arrêt en représentation
ils font de la ils font de la politique
mais ils font du théâtre et d'ailleurs
les bons politiques sont des bons
théâtraux enfin des bons des des ils ont
des tribuns c'est pas forcément ceux qui
ont les meilleures idées mais je veux
dire ceux qui sont très très à l'aise en
public qui qui n'ont pas les discours
affichés qui sont là en train
d'arranguer ils sont bons
jouer un président de la République ça
se prépare comment par exemple est-ce
que on échange avec d'anciens présidents
de la République je sais pas ce que vous
avez eu l'occasion de rencontrer
François Hollande Nicolas Sarkozy pour
vous inspirer un peu de ce qui j'ai eu
l'occasion de rencontrer de rencontrer
François Hollande mais dans les
discussions que j'ai eues avec lui
c'était pas forcément pour lui parler de
ce qui était la fonction du président de
la République c'était plus sur des des
choses anecdotiques un peu qu'on peut
remettre aussi dans une dans une série
il se trouve que la série sous contrôle
est une série un peu décalée qui est qui
fait que moi j'aime beaucoup et qui
manque je trouve en France c'est la
série qui fait le pas de côté c'est la
série qui parle de la politique mais
qu'il a qu'il a sublime parce que c'est
jamais comme ça ça devrait se passer
c'est-à-dire pour ça que ça s'appelle
sous contrôle parce que quand vous
verrez la série vous rendrez compte que
rien n'est sous contrôle et en fait au
lieu de nous dire que tout est sous
contrôle comme ça a été le cas on va pas
revenir historiquement dans ce qui s'est
passé politiquement mais ça a été quand
même le cas on nous a dit pas puis en
fait pour mettre les masques etc quand
des gens qui soient des politiques ou
qui soit même des des médecins nous
disent que tout est sous contrôle moi je
m'en méfie en fait parce que j'ai
l'impression que justement c'est pas le
cas donc il faut il faut pas avoir peur
de cet humour là et c'est ce que raconte
la série d'ailleurs et parfois c'est
fiction française autour du monde
politique donne aussi l'impression que
un petit côté tous pourris il y a un
petit côté qui peut ressortir ça vous
interpelle vous trouvez ça donc ça
m'interpelle et ça m'intéresse pas en
fait je pense que le politique le côté
politique tous pourris apporte des
choses qui peuvent aller dans des
extrêmes qui sont dommageables pour une
société et que
je crois qu'au contraire il y a des gens
qui ont des qui sont des gens de
conviction et que
la politique fait avancer fait avancer
les choses avec le avec des mouvements
citoyens mais la politique c'est très
important et le côté tous pourri je je
déteste ça parce que ça ça avoir avec un
avec une politique en particulier je
trouve c'est des gens qui est au sein
même de la politique qu'ils font 10 de
toute façon il y a que nous parce que
vous voyez les autres sont pourris donc
c'est en fait c'est très populiste et
j'aime pas ça du tout on va passer à
notre séquence traditionnelle la
séquence des photos
j'ai quelques photos à vous montrer
Laurent Stocker la première c'est celle
de Donald Trump devant le tribunal de
New York dites-vous entouré de ses
avocats mais justement c'était ma
question alors premier ex-président
américain inculpé de l'histoire il est
visé par 34 chefs d'accusation parfois
la réalité dépasse la fiction ah oui bah
de toute façon c'est
comme Richard III des personnages de
théâtre
je le jouerai déjà avec une j'aurais
besoin d'un bon coiffeur parce que je
pense que si je jouais ce personnage ce
qu'il faudrait c'est lui mettre de
l'humour alors que justement il y en a
pas beaucoup et
c'est il y aurait plein de il y aurait
plein de séquences à faire sur sur le
décoiffage sur le sur le fait qu'il
serait déstabilisé parce que il aurait
des problèmes de mèche on est toujours
question mais je le jouerai comment
faire c'est toujours difficile de jouer
un personnage parce que
quel que soit le personnage quand vous
le jouez vous devez le défendre donc
vous devez vous êtes comme un avocat
toujours même la pire des crapuls la
pire des ordures c'est c'est de lui
montrer le la faille le côté humain
pourquoi c'est devenu ce qu'il est en
fait ça ça va avoir avec la tragédie
parce que la tragédie depuis le 6e
siècle c'est cette façon de montrer que
les choses nous appartiennent mais ne
nous appartiennent pas il y a ce côté
conscient inconscient qui sont dus à
plein de choses le reste c'est du
mélodrame mais la tragédie c'est ça et
lui c'est un personnage
tragique je trouve tragique pour le le
monde une autre photo c'est celle de
Guillaume Diop peut-être vous
connaissez-vous prenez danseur étoile
noire de l'Opéra de Paris en plus de 300
ans d'existence il se dit heureux et
fier et il dit surtout que c'est
important parce que ça fait lui une
référence qui permettra à d'autres
enfants noirs de peut-être se projeter
et de rêver ce à quoi il est par devenu
lui vous faites pas ouais vous faites
partie de ceux qui disent enfin il était
temps
française aussi
il était temps
qu'il y ait d'autres acteurs qui
représentent la diversité et que enfin
c'est quand même incroyable le temps que
ça a mis c'est très français aussi ça
vous allez en Angleterre
le le l'acteur noir qui joue Hamlet ça
ne pose de problème à personne vous
allez en France et ça m'est arrivé dans
une mise en scène de Marcel Bozonnet où
on faisait Tartuffe ou l'acteur qui
faisait Orgon était noir ça ne posait de
problème à personne sauf à certains
spectateurs qui écrivaient des lettres
racistes disons-le et donc ça c'est
vraiment problématique et c'est et c'est
très franco-français il est temps de
vous voyez que que le moi j'aime bien
les notions de crossover de faire du
théâtre et puis de faire aussi du cinéma
de la télévision et des voix
c'est très anglais ça c'est très je veux
pour ça en tout cas le modèle artistique
français qui se soit pour la danse ou le
théâtre a besoin vraiment de s'inspirer
de l'Angleterre
le stockage est une dernière question
qui est en lien avec notre lieu nous
sommes entourés de quatre statues
chacune représentant une vertu il y a
ici la sagesse ici la prudence ici la
justice et derrière moi l'éloquence
peut-être il y avait vous déjà réfléchi
y a-t-il une de ses vertus qui vous
caractérise ou qui vous parle
particulièrement non
[Rires]
la prudence peut-être
ça aurait pu être l'élo comment ça
pourrait tout ce que vous nous avez dit
sur ouais mais comme ça fait vraiment
partie de mon métier après voilà la
sagesse
peut-être un peu de prudence quelquefois
il faut un peu de prudence quand on est
jeune comédien on manque de prudence
puis avec l'âge on a on a un peu plus
prudent et compris sur les plateaux
quand on monte sur un plateau de théâtre
pour faire attention je croyais que vous
parliez de ce plateau tous les plateaux
les
j'aime beaucoup les j'aime beaucoup les
références au théâtre japonais
les Japonais disent quand on monte sur
un plateau il faut faire très attention
il faut pas monter sur un plateau
n'importe comment parce que si vous
montez mal sur un plateau les dieux du
théâtre se vengent et donc il faut faire
attention de pas de pas fâcher les dieux
du théâtre d'accord ce sera le mot de la
fin la phrase de la fin merci merci
infiniment
d'un regard merci à vous de nous avoir
suivi émission vous pouvez évidemment
retrouver en replay et en podcast à très
bientôt sur Public Sénat merci merci à
vous
[Musique]